candy canes come in many different
colors and sizes candy makers start by
cooking up a big batch of sugar water
and corn syrup
next they prepare a mix of starch and
peppermint flavoring as they blend
together the flavoring binds to the
starch the flavoring mix is emptied into
the middle of the syrupy slab then the
whole thing is fed into a machine that
folds the batch repeatedly using shovels
and a plunger this distributes the
flavouring evenly
cold water has piped into the shovels
and the kneading table to pull the candy
cane mix so it takes on a stiffer
consistency which is needed for the next
step the automated Polar's these pullers
stretch the mixture around a metal post
this action aerates the candy turning it
white
this batch will make 3200 candy canes
but there's still a lot more work to do
the candy has rolled into a fat log as
heaters warm it until it's pliable
enough to shape next they roll strips of
red color candy a worker stretches and
folds it to widen the strip two of the
red strips are arranged on either side
of the white candy the block of candy
weighs 100 pounds so it takes two
workers to transfer it to a batch roller
the batch roller cylinders roll the
candy thinner and thinner dramatically
reducing the logs diameter until it
reaches candy cane dimensions a torch
moves across the candy to keep it
pliable the sugary batch travels between
wheels that slim it down even more
the rope of candy moves forward in a
wave-like fashion this gives it some
slack so it doesn't stretch as it moves
through the next set of wheels the candy
rope moves through two angled belts that
twist it and a chain of knives cut the
twisted rope to candy cane size
this production has been perfectly
choreographed
here a roll of cellophane unwinds and a
device wraps it around the candy sticks
a blast of hot air shrinks the
cellophane on the ends of the Canes now
it's time for these candy sticks to get
their signature crooks
this machine caught a Crooker tech bends
the ends an overhead bracket brush
gently secures the Canes because though
they're pliable enough to bend they're
still fragile
there's a camera inside this robotic arm
that spots the candy canes on the
conveyor belt before the arm picks them
up two at a time it places them in
cardboard packages by the Dozen
it takes about a half hour to make a box
of candy canes but they're sure to come
to a very sticky end in less time